we were aspiring to be real warriors
tough battle-hardened seals
but the wisdom of this simple act has
been proven
to me many times over there is one habit
that i have adopted in the last three
years
that has fundamentally changed me as a
business person
if you leave your time to randomness
you are stealing from your greatness
we're in a war against distraction right
now and what we really have to do is
optimize our energy quiet your mind
and get your 30 minutes of sleep and
you'll see it makes a
really really big difference want to be
happy build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the 10
habits that will change
your life enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one make your
bed every morning in seal training
my instructors who at the time were all
vietnam veterans
would show up in my barracks room and
the first thing they do is inspect my
bed
if you did it right the corners would be
square the covers would be pulled tight
the pillow centered just under the
headboard and the extra blanket folded
neatly at the foot of the rack
it was a simple task mundane at best but
every morning
we were required to make our bed to
perfection
it seemed a little ridiculous at the
time particularly in light of the fact
that we were aspiring to be real
warriors tough battle-hardened seals
but the wisdom of this simple act has
been proven
to me many times over
if you make your bed every morning you
will have accomplished the first
task of the day it will give you a small
sense of pride
and it will encourage you to do another
task and another
and another and by the end of the day
that one task completed
will have turned into many tasks
completed making your bed will also
reinforce the fact
that the little things in life matter if
you can't do the little things right
you'll never be able to do the big
things right and if by chance you have a
miserable day
you will come home to a bed that is made
that you made and a made bed gives you
encouragement
that tomorrow will be better so if you
want to change the world
start off by making your bed habit
number two take care of your body and
mind with warren buffett
70 years ago i was in high school
almost a third as long as the country
has been around
and when i was in high school i really
only had two things on my mind
girls and cars and and it wasn't doing
very well with girls so we'll talk about
cars
but let's just imagine that when we
finish
i'm going to let each one of you pick
out
the car of your choice sounds good
doesn't it
uh pick it out any color you name it
it'll be tied up with a bow
and it'll be at your house tomorrow and
you
say well what's the catch
and the catch is that it's the only car
you're going to get in your lifetime
now what are you going to do knowing
that that's the only car
you're ever going to have and you love
that car you're going to take care of it
like you cannot believe now what i'd
like to suggest
you're not going to get only one car in
your lifetime
but you're going to get one body and one
mind and that's all you're going to get
and that body and mind feels terrific
now
but it has to last you a lifetime habit
number three
block your time with brendan burchard if
you're not doing block
time here's what your day might look
like
you have all these different slots of
time right
and you're just going to plug in as you
go through the day
you're going to plug in oh i'll work
some there and
i'll work some there and then i'll try
to cram stuff up right at the end of the
day i'll try to cram that sucker in
any crammers crammers crammers cameras
okay just checking
no judgment no judgment you're just not
going as fast as you could
that's all crammers they're i love
crammers
yeah just like because they're easy to
get to move faster because you do have
that diligence
of when there's a deadline and it's on
you can go which
really serves you but we got to take you
from a crammer to a preparer to a high
performer
and the way that we do that is to look
at this and go
listen if you keep leaving all these
time slots to randomness
what happens
is they start to get filled
with the big d
distraction
[Applause]
some reason it seems like this hit home
for some people
i don't know why how many recognize what
i'm talking about here
so now you add up
take this out you might not be thinking
too seriously about it but let's say
that's like a day
one two three four five six seven eight
work hours
you didn't know i drew that on purpose
if you leave your time
to randomness you are stealing from your
greatness
if you leave your time to randomness you
are stealing from your greatness bit by
bit hour by eight
hour day by day week by week month by
month quarter by quarter year by year
and decade by decade
and it's the little things like this
where you're like oh my gosh i didn't
get
anything done because you've got all
these random approaches
to your day
and so for those who are like but
brandon i'm a free spirit
i'm like oh god i love free spirits me
too
let's go on a yoga retreat i don't have
any time
oh free spirit no time for yoga retreat
you know why free spreading i don't time
for real go to retreat because they got
a discipline
if they had some discipline free spirit
would have time for some yoga retreat
so if you want more free time you need
more discipline time
it's so simple all right my friend evan
carmichael's book listen
humans are built to serve some people
are built to serve the world
others want to serve the 25 people
closest to them
but in either case humans are built to
serve so if you're not happy right now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
habit number four get rid of your phone
with mel robbins there is one habit
that i have adopted in the last three
years
that has fundamentally changed me as a
business person
and it has also changed my ability to
manage
my emotions so i don't get hijacked
i do not allow my phone
in the bedroom i know the research
deloitte just did a study based on phone
use alone and 33
of people are reading emails in the
middle of the night
i know that if you go to bed and the
phone is right next to you
right so you go to bed because you need
your phone you know somebody might need
you and
you sleep you know if this is right here
and it's not closed and the blue light
is on
they've done studies where you have
people at a table and the researcher
will put their phone
on the table not even my phone the
researcher's phone and the brain lights
up like crazy
just with the presence of a phone the
research around the phone and sleep
is so stunning that if you were to adopt
one radical thing today other than the
five-second rule
try putting your phone outside your
bedroom turn off
the bus so you don't hear it
tell people who need to reach you to
call you my kids i have a kid in college
a kid who's
you know high school kid in middle
school if there's an emergency
call me there is nothing happening on
your phone at two o'clock in the morning
that's important but if you allow
yourself to become
a tool of this this is supposed to be
your tool for selling
your tool for communicating and we're
all becoming the tool here's the other
thing common sense wise that i want you
to understand you wake up
the alarm goes off what do you do
so you're not even vertical
and you're reading emails and what is in
these emails
other people's crap so if you don't have
boundaries with this puppy
it's gonna impact sleep it's gonna
impact how much money you make it's
gonna impact how much self-control you
have
and so when i put this thing outside the
bedroom
and i wake up i walk over to where the
phone is it's plugged into my bathroom i
turn it off i don't look at it yet
i give myself five minutes five minutes
before i tune into the world
to actually tune in up here and say
what's the one thing i'm going to get
done today
that really matters to me if you're the
kind of person that feels like you don't
have control over your day that your day
gets hijacked that you can't get to the
priorities that you're always behind the
ball
this one planning thing will change your
life no phone in the bedroom
turn it off when the alarm goes off five
minutes five lousy minutes
five lousy minutes before you tune in to
the rest of the world
and if you've got the kind of job where
you've got to check it get up 10 minutes
earlier
you have control over this stuff and it
is so important that you take it
seriously now because
you're living at the slowest moment of
your entire life
habit number five sleep more and
meditate with kobe bryant
lesson one get an additional 30 minutes
of sleep
a night take it as a challenge try to
find that space
quiet your mind and get your 30 minutes
of sleep and you'll see it makes a
really really big difference my my sleep
habits were
horrendous to say the least i mean i
i've always had a hard time sleeping you
know i couldn't
figure out how to shut my brain off so
what made the light bulb come on is that
i went out there and played a game
and i played like crap and i was like
why am i playing like crap because i've
been practicing these same moves over
and over and over
but yet um i couldn't execute them
properly
i was feeling sluggish i was feeling
lethargic and i knew it wasn't because
of my training
because i had trained obsessively so
then i started looking at
other things and that's when i came to
the realization that hey kobe you're not
21 years old anymore buddy like maybe
the fact that you're sleeping two three
hours a night maybe that has something
to do with the fact that you're playing
like crap
and that's when i started really
evaluating those things
and i'd say lesson two would be just
five minutes of quiet time
five minutes for you to be mindful and
to just sit
and uh and and find that inner voice and
uh
and and just kind of listen to the self
and uh
preferably would be in the morning as
you start your day
i meditate every day i meditate every
day and um
i do it in the mornings and uh i do it
for about 10 to 15 minutes
and uh i think it's important because it
just it
it sets me up for the rest of the day
you know it helps me it's like it's like
it's like having an
anchor you know it's
if i don't do it i feel like i'm
constantly chasing the day
as opposed to being able to be
controlled and dictate the day not that
you're
you know calling the shots on what comes
forward
but the fact that i am set and ready for
whatever may come my way
you know i have a calmness about
whatever comes my way and a poise
um and that comes from starting the
morning off with meditation for me it's
really just
just listening to to my inner self i
mean
there's that's basically it like you you
sit in silence
and you just allow these thoughts to
come forward and
you get a chance to observe um
the self in in things that
may be lying beneath the surface that if
you don't have that time to sit quietly
on your own you'll never pay attention
to
you know because if you think about it
like you know the reality is we're
paying attention to so many things that
are going on around us
we're constantly taking selfies we're
constantly taking pictures to post on
instagram and all these other things
we're constantly observing everything
that's around us but
we don't take the time to really observe
what's going on inside of ourselves
and uh that's what meditation is for me
in
2000 we had a new head coach that came
to the los angeles lakers by the name of
phil jackson
and phil was just coming off and winning
six championships with the bulls
and he was really big on mindfulness a
really big old meditation
and it wasn't an option for us so we'd
sit
in our film room and he'd turn the
lights out
and he would we would meditate as a
group and he'd teach us mindfulness
and it really connected with me because
he was teaching mindfulness through
something that i was extremely
passionate about which was the game of
basketball
so it was told through the lens of this
is going to help you here
and so i had this curiosity about it
and um that was my introduction to
meditation
and then seeing the poise that we played
with the fact that we can be in a
hostile environment with fans yelling
and screaming and
you know pressure situations and it in
it having no effect on us
because we were never too high never too
low we were just in the moment
and felt very secure in who we were
and that was my introduction to
meditation
i had a great experience which really i
learned a lot about meditation through
this experience i was
i was on a jet ski and i took the jet
ski out
in the ocean and i just kind of sat and
i just let the current just take me
wherever it was gonna take me
and i really saw a lot of meditation
through that moment because i wasn't
trying to control
the moment i wasn't trying to force
myself upon the waves and dictate where
i was going to god just let the waves
take me there
and it was a lot of peacefulness
involved in that habit number six
use the 20 20 20 formula with robin
sharma
one of the lines from right out of the
5am club is
one of the dnas of legendary is
longevity
so if you look at the picassos the
jean-michel basquiat you look at the
great
sports champions you look at the great
history makers
they were much better at energy
management than time management
and so we're in a war against
distraction right now and what we really
have to do is
optimize our energy how do i do it well
i mean i get to the morning routine
which
which the whole book is based on but
it's really quite powerful because if
you start
your day with sweaty exercise you're
actually going to
activate a pharmacy of mastery that
exists in every human brain
i know you love the neuroscience you're
going to release bdnf which is
brain-derived neurotrophic factor
that's going to actually accelerate your
processing it's actually going to repair
brain cells that have been damaged by
stress you're going to release
the neurotransmitter dopamine which is
the the
fire neurotransmitter which we all need
as entrepreneurs and business builders
and
and servants of humanity cortisol
the fear hormone is highest in the
morning so
exercising first thing in the morning is
going to reduce that i'm getting into my
20 20 20 formula but i mention it
because it is a way to maximize your
energy
so talk to us about the 20 20 20 i mean
you sort of
um started it there with the the sweaty
exercise but what's the rest of that
formula which is pretty powerful
sure so the new book is all about rising
at 5 a.m and that's because if you look
at the great creatives and the great
saints and the great humanitarians and
the great titans of industry
many of them got up at 5am even right
now you've got tim cook and you've got
howard schultz and it goes on and on
before the sun rises is the time of
least distraction
before the sun rises where you can build
intimacy and fluency with what you want
to stand for
in your day before the sun rises the
luxury and tranquility of the early
morning hours
you can do that deep inner work that
will allow you to go out in the world
and
and play at your best so what the 20 20
20 formula is is simply this there's
three pockets the first pocket is move
five to five twenty and you get into the
sweaty exercise because like i mentioned
it releases
neurotransmitters it reduces the
cortisol it increases your metabolic
rate which gives you more energy
so now and serotonin as well which gives
you joy
so now it's 520 fundamentally you feel
different you have energy your state is
strong
you've got a fire in your belly and
you've accelerated your focus
520 to 540 is the second pocket
of the 20 20 20 formula which is reflect
we live in a world where a lot of people
are busy being busy but what's the point
of being
busy around climbing the wrong mount
everests
and so clarity is one of the dnas of
mastery
you know this if you talk to the titans
of industry and you talk to the people
really getting traction around their
ambition
these are people who have a monomaniacal
focus on the few things that matter
they have an obsession bordering on a
possession around the few priorities
they want to build their life around and
so 520 to
540 the second pocket you write in a
journal
you meditate you visualize
you do what i call in the book a
blueprint for a beautiful day
or you just sit in solitude and you
think and you ponder and you reflect
and then the final pocket is 5 40 to 6
o'clock and this is the victory hour
the final pocket is grow but if you look
at the greatest billionaires i've
coached many billionaires over the past
20 years if you look at the greatest
producers on the planet these people
have one thing in common they are
ridiculously curious
and no matter how much money they make
and no matter how much impact they
have they maintain a white belt
mentality
one of the keys to epic performance
is a relentless commitment to daily
growth so that's the 20 20 20 formula
that the 5 am method
is built around and the premise is
basically this as you begin your day
so you hand craft the rest of your day
and if you have consistently great days
you're going to have consistently great
weeks quarters
a year and a lifetime so your days are
life and miniature and you got to get
those
mornings calibrated if you really want
to win habit number seven
create a vision with dean graziosi in
today's world we are so busy with
social media and our phones sitting next
to us and facebook
and instagram and emails and text
messages
that we're running faster than we ever
have in our entire life
so when you're so busy it's like we have
a cloud around us
and setting goals just doesn't work for
most people in today's crazy fast-paced
world when's the last time you tried to
sit down
and look forward to where you're going
to be in a year or five years it's hard
right
it doesn't work anymore so i want to
give you a little hack don't set goals
create a vision for yourself and here's
how you do it let's pretend it's a year
from now
and you're looking back on your year and
it was the best financial year of your
entire life
you're making the money you want you
have the confidence you want you have
the courage you want you're living in
the house you want you have
the job you want you're treating your
husband your wife your children your
parents the way you want
you're walking around looking younger
feeling better what does that look like
to you
write that down as fast as you can write
down a vision for yourself instead of
looking
forward you're pretending it's a year
from now you're looking back
best year of your life write it down
that's your vision that becomes the new
way to goals
again goals is looking forward vision is
looking backwards
habit number eight practice being
uncomfortable with david goggins no
matter how far you get in life
you have to be able to go back to
scratch in your mind
at a moment's notice you can never get
so
far beyond scratch what that means is
when you accomplish something in life if
you want to go back to scratch
and go back to that seven dollar a month
place where i once lived
and visit that place for a long period
of time if you were here
when you went back to scratch you would
now be here scratch is what makes you
better
scratch friction obstacles create growth
there's no friction when you're this far
up in the game anymore
you think there is that's right when you
change so much the friction is
is is minor because why
i'm sore i'm gonna get a massage today
i'm hungry i'm gonna eat today the
refrigerator is always full
so your comforts are now so your
discomfort is now
very miniscule to your discomfort back
here in the seven dollar a month place
so you have to go back to the total
discomfort
to then raise your level of where you're
at now
i'm not saying stay there and stay there
visit
visit it and then you raise your level
take a day trip
that's right yeah always take day trips
yeah
don't stay there that's right but take a
day trip so when you complete some
massive obstacle and challenge whatever
the adversity that you force
upon yourself because these are all
curated
experiences for yourself right you're
scratching constantly
what happens now since this was five
years ago you would just leave you want
to take the medal you would just go on
to the next
what happens now do you take you know a
day to reflect
a moment 10 minutes like how does the
process work and then how do you get
back to visiting the seven dollar
uh you know place you lived in now
i don't have to go back and visit it i
don't have to think about it
it lives with me now every day of my
damn
life that feeling that i had to go back
and think about
i found a way this habit
how did you do it it's constantly there
i have a self-talk
i have a self-talk it's called my cookie
jar
it's a constant reminder of david guy
every day of my life
i believe in quiet there's no growth
outside of quiet the the world's too
noisy
your mind needs quiet for you to find
who you are people
what's my purpose why am i here you're
not going to find it nowadays unless you
lock yourself
in a quiet room in your mind and find it
it's too noisy for me i could be in a
busy street in new york city
horn's honking and i'm walking around
with like
nothing it's me and myself in a quiet
spot
and when you are constantly reflecting
on who you are where you've been the
journey you've gone through the journey
you can continue going through
the feeling is always there you don't
allow the world
to pull you so fast that you forget
you don't allow yourself to pull you so
fast that you forget
it's not about staying in that moment
it's about you want to get to the point
where that feeling
follows you like breathing
because a part of your life part of your
dna but
it's made like these callouses on my
hands right now they're made
yeah they are now on my brain this is
now a part of me
it's a daily process a part of me and
how i go back to seven dollar month
place
all the time is now i go out
and i dig fireline i'm a wildland
firefighter i don't need to do it
i'm a 43 year old man i work with 27
year old kids
yeah i'm a rookie every day i'm a rookie
feels like
and why do you do it that's why i do it
man habit number nine
beat the sun up with grant cardone
grant rant of the day the one you need
to live with wake up to every day
is that right there okay
beat the sun up folks you got to beat
the sun up if you can't beat up the
roll-up of the sunnah
you're going to get beat up in life okay
i've been doing this for a long time now
say beat that thing up that monster out
there that warms this planet
that nourishes and gives us light
but you can't live a 10x life if you're
not beating the sun up
so many of you complain about how much
time you have you don't have time man
because you don't beat the sun up get
started early
and when you get started early that
means you need to shut it down early
okay shut it down early so you get sleep
i was
i was i was asleep last night at nine
o'clock so i could beat the sun up
tomorrow this morning and see
the world wake up with me inhabit number
10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is reprogram your
mind with dr joe dispenza
okay well most people number one they
get up in the morning they check their
cell phone they check their text their
whatsapp their
facebook they post something on facebook
drive to work the same way do the same
thing
so they're in a program they've actually
lost their free will to the program wow
so if you start your day and you start
your day with this simple question
what is the greatest ideal of myself
that i can be today
you ask yourself that question now
listen your body's going to go like well
we got to get a cup of coffee and you've
got to get
i'm tired yeah and you got to go ah body
uh you're not the mind i'm the mind
right now you're going to sit here i'm
going to feed you
you're you're gonna get your coffee
you're gonna do all those things but
right now
this is my time you're gonna obey me
right
so now the body's no longer the mind
you're the mind and so when it wants to
get up and you become aware of it
and return back to the present moment
every time you do that's a victory
and you're changing some aspect of
yourself so then
ask yourself i do this all the time
write down four thoughts
that you're going to stay conscious of
the whole day i can't it's too hard
you'd be surprised
the moment you become conscious of what
those thoughts are how unconscious
you've been to them all day
for weeks on end write down what you
speak
how you speak four things you want to
change how you act
how do you how do you act you complain
do you blame you make excuses you feel
sorry for yourself
that's a victim consciousness what
emotions do you live by is it possible
that you're so used to living by guilt
you don't even know it's guilt it just
feels like you
you allow your energy to drop become
conscious of those states of mind and
body and
review them and say this is the old self
then say what thoughts do i want to fire
and wire in my brain
and start firing and wiring and start
feeling it
what behaviors will i demonstrate today
what choices will i make one day one
lifetime
just like you did rehearse them rehearse
the whole entire thing
begin to install the neurological
hardware in your brain
and if you keep installing it the
hardware is going to become a software
program you're going to start thinking
and acting that way
and then here's a tough part can you
teach
your body emotionally what your future
is gonna feel like before it's made
manifest
and don't get up until you feel that way
now practice that for a few days
and then see if you can stay in that
state and watch
all of a sudden all those weird doors
start opening for you super nice
synchronicities whatever they are number
two
take up time at the end of your day the
end of your day before you lay down
and give thanks for your life and feel
gratitude
and really teach your body what it feels
like
the emotional signature of gratitude
when gratitude means
you're getting something if i give you
something that's of value
you would say thank you because you
would feel it right so when you're
receiving
you're giving thanks so gratitude is the
ultimate state of receiving
so then people only accept believe and
surrender to the thoughts equal to their
emotional state
so if you're in a state of gratitude
every thought's going to make it right
down into your body
if you're saying i'm i'm healthy i'm
healthy i'm healthy i'm wealthy and
wealthy i'm wealthy and your body's
programmed the negativity it's saying no
you're not no you're not knowing i
thought it's going to stop right here
so as you elevate your state there are
about
1200 different chemical reactions that
go on in the body that begin to restore
and repair the body in a state of
gratitude
and so we've done the research to prove
that 10 minutes
and just feel it with all of your heart
that's it third thing and
and very important take time
whenever it is sit down close your eyes
and begin to just open your awareness to
the space around you and just
sense it and pay attention to it become
more aware of it
the act of opening your awareness begins
to reduce the stress hormones
and creates more coherent brainwave
states i'm doing it right now
it's just a practice yeah it's just a
practice and the more you do it
the better you get at it now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your specific plan of action
for the next
week when you just watch a video and get
motivated by it you have a 35
chance of following through but when you
get motivated and then create
a specific plan of action you have a 91
chance of following through that's what
we do here believe nation we get
motivated but then we do
something about it and when you commit
to other people you increase your
chances
even further of following through so
what was your biggest takeaway from this
video
and then what is your plan of action
around for this week
put it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate
you the reason why you are not chasing
your big dream is because you are afraid
that it's going to fail
you're afraid that it's not going to
work and what people will say about you
and what you will think
about yourself but what's the
alternative it's sitting on your idea
for years
never taking your shot because you're
afraid and living the rest of your life
in regret
knowing that you had an opportunity but
were too afraid to take it
the way to not have regrets is to be
always taking action to as soon as you
get an idea go do something about it
i had a great podcast with my friend
mark drager a couple weeks ago a month
ago or so
where he was asking me about regret and
i used to always tell this story of
imagine you have a hangnail how much
that hurts and it's all you can think
about when you have a hangnail but if
somebody punches you in the arm you
don't
feel the hang nail anymore because this
hurts more
right you focus on what hurts more and
suddenly this one doesn't hurt as much
that's how i would use regret i would
always think about whatever pain that
i'm in right now this thing that i want
to do
but i'm afraid i would imagine that this
thing is going to be the best thing of
all time that
this video i'm going to make this speech
i'm going to give this clan i'm going to
make
is going to be the best of all time and
if i don't do it i'm going to regret it
for the rest of my life for decades i'm
going to regret not taking action
and so the pain of doing the thing
is the hang nail and the future pain of
regret for decades
is to punch to the arm and so it
inflicts so much pain on me that then i
have to go off and do that thing
and i use that for
over a decade over a decade
that's the lens through which i made
decisions and saw the world
but for the past two years i haven't
done that at all i haven't talked about
it
i haven't done it for myself because i
talk about the things that i live
and i'm thinking why why don't i do that
anymore why don't i use
future regret to fuel me
and i found this because i'm always
taking action because as soon as i get
an idea i do something
and so i don't judge the idea i don't
say why me i don't ponder on the idea i
don't
i don't just default to strategizing and
thinking i don't think why did i come up
with this why am i thinking about this i
just do it
you get an idea you go off and do it and
that's been my
mindset for the past year and a half two
years
and as a result the breakthrough was
you don't live with regret if you're
always taking
action on the ideas that you have you
don't live with regret you might regret
some of the things you end up doing
but most of the things that you regret
and other things done as the actions
undone
not undone not taken the action is not
taken you don't regret the things that
you did
you get the things that you didn't do
that's most people right there may be a
couple things that you regret that you
did but for the most part
it's the things that you are too afraid
to do that you regret for the rest of
your life
and so if you're constantly doing if
you're constantly taking action if
you're always jumping
then you don't have regrets and it's
been an interesting way that
i now see the world and hopefully you
can learn from as soon as you get an
idea you go off and you do something you
do that you won't have any regrets
[Music]
if you want to know the five habits for
a happy and lasting relationship check
out the video right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there people ask me what's this one of
the keys relationship
physical intimacy it's a box you better
be checking if you want
to create intensity